l'avion de chasse américain f 35
pourrait-il être à l'origine de l'accord
entre les émirats arabes unis et israël
c'est du moins la thèse du quotidien
yedioth ahronoth le journal le plus
vendu en israël assure que le deal
conclu sous la houlette de washington
prévoyait la vente d'avions de combat f
35 aux émirats arabes unis
une information démentie par israël même
si le ministre des affaires étrangères
des émirats
anwar gargash indiqué récemment aux
films tanks atlantique comme celle que
l'achat des f-35 à washington était une
possibilité
l achat d'armements à quelque chose qui
est sur la table nous avons des demandes
légitimes qui sont là nous devons les
obtenir
à mon avis maintenant tout l'idée d'un
état de belligérance ou de guerre avec
israël n'existe plus une question
éminemment sensible qu'à washington
garantie à israël la primauté au
moyen-orient du matériel militaire
américain de pointe ce qui assure l état
hébreu d'être le mieux armé de la région
quoi qu'il en soit l'accord conclu entre
l'état hébreu et les émirats arabes unis
pourraient accélérer la course aux
armements dans la région
les spéculations vont d'ailleurs bon
train sur les prochains candidats
possibles à une normalisation avec
israël comme le bahreïn oman ou encore
le soudan le secrétaire d'état américain
nike pompéo entame d'ailleurs une
tournée au moyen orient dès aujourd'hui
pour discuter de l'accord entre tel-aviv
et abu dhabi avec la possibilité d'une
extension à d'autres pays arabes